à méthane
eric zemmour
comment vous l'auteur des rats de garde
avec patrick poivre d'arvor qui est un
ouvrage sur la presse people et des
paparazzi comment vous pouvez dans votre
bouquin parler du suicide de laurence la
fille aînée des chirac qui est
anorexique et qui est une sorte d'
enfant caché du couple est ce que vous
trouvez que c'est bien pour le suicide
de laurence bernadette elle même en
parle donc sa mère et deuxièmement je
faisais un portrait de chirac ce n'est
pas un livre théorique politique
c'était un portrait de l'homme je
voulais faire un roman une espèce de
roman vrai de jacques chirac comme un
personnage romanesque et donc j'avais
besoin de montrer
toutes les facettes de ce type et
justement pour expliquer ce que vous
avez remarqué tout à l'heure c'est à
dire qu'il sait que le bonheur n'existe
pas et que c'est un type profondément
malheureux je pense que le drame que vit
sa fille
fais partie de ceux de ce malheur
profond vous savez je raconte aussi une
scène quand pasqua
vous savez quand elle se suicide elle l
hôpital et le premier le premier à venir
c'est pasqua alors qu'ils sont en guerre
politique et que les chinois qui sont en
thaïlande à ce moment là les sharks en
thaïlande et ils reprennent l'avion et
les passe quoi bon les veillé toute la
nuit et quand pasqua sort de l'hôpital
pasqua dit
vraiment on peut rapprocher ce qu'on
veut à chirac mais il porte sa croix
il sait que sa fille est malade parce
qu'il a fait de la politique on rallume
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu